oh wait
capture device
um a window capture here we go
okay guys let me know if this audio is
okay
because i've been struggling all day and
i'm just trying to
see if i even got this correct
okay wait wait let me go to the
okay okay okay
okay there's the live stream
all right
so i'm about to start it let me know if
the audio levels are okay i'm checking
on my phone
like the stream comments so i can see it
are women destroying the image of
marriage
women man for the wrong reasons uh
i'm gonna answer it this way i think
that
the marriage in hollywood has destroyed
the image of marriage
um disney has destroyed the image of
marriage so it doesn't surprise me that
women are marrying for romantic love
um romantic love and
and that kind of stuff um so
sadly so many of our women are marrying
for true love and in my opinion
that's the wrong reason because that's
not what gets you through
once i actually sat down and talked to
somebody
i became a proponent because you learned
coping skills and ways of communicating
uh that i you know that that i never had
before and then
you can use them as as necessary how
many times people watch my show and say
damn
you're a better one to me g i couldn't
do that
yeah it's a learned thing um
does he mean like coping to talking to
people that are like unruly
also let me know guys is this audio
level okay i think one of the major
things
is is especially in the black community
we are so
christian we really believe that we're
not being faithful to god
uh if we if we go to uh
if we go get counseling but i say god
made counselors too
um that's why i'm i if
yeah i'm big on that man uh especially
for black men
because um we just had a young rapper
kill himself right
a little loaded look
you know our culture is different we're
quicker to jones on you
than uh then say i hear you but there's
sometimes
if if if jr called anton
and there's sometimes you can hear
something in a man's voice
when he hit that that crack you know
what i mean that crack
he's like hey man i you like
i'm on my way fam you know you got to
get to your homeboy
and quick because there's maybe a loaded
45 and a ball of jack on the table
and we gotta learn do you guys feel like
men aren't able to express their
feelings because sometimes
i think that guys are like afraid to
express their feelings because
they're afraid like one the girl isn't
gonna like them anymore and like
two that other guys are gonna make fun
of them do you guys think that's a thing
um obviously i'm like i talk to girls
more than guys so i
wouldn't know learn how to
extend some grace to one another as men
because black men
in particular don't have a lot of
outlets and we aren't
necessarily comfortable uh sharing
um personal stuff with with each other
because
you know like it or not we we don't want
it to get out right
but the more we start dealing with
therapy the more we start understanding
that
you know that there are some things that
are out of bounds
per se and and allowing folks to be
human
man we're gonna be better off because
i i think you know
this is my personal opinion i got
nothing to base it on but
i look at what we survived as black
people and if you put that on any other
race of folks i don't know
could they have made it to where we are
the fact that we are still breathing
is amazing but um i think it's important
for brothers in particular
because we don't get enough validation
and support and affirmation
and we got to learn to get up to each
other i'll say this and i'll get a mic
up
uh oftentimes i have a young brother he
doesn't even know he wants to give me a
compliment but he don't know how
you're like i like instead of saying
like the way you dress like this like
that's the saddest thing i've ever heard
in my life
you don't know how it's like
that you'll be sliding i don't know what
that mean but that's just not
i don't know what that means either and
it reminds me of what i
and what it reminds me of is it reminds
me of when with all my college education
everything else i still
lacked the emotional vocabulary to
express
a feeling that
that's that's dangerous especially when
you put testosterone
in it hey man i just wanted to tell you
i appreciate that balance that you added
this is the side of kevin samuels that
you don't
hear too many people talk about like you
always hear about him
kind of being an [ __ ] right or being
very direct very rude
but people don't really talk about how
empathetic and how he does preach things
like mental health and like
therapy for men and he really does have
that like empathy
for people but sometimes you don't it
doesn't really come across a lot of the
time because um
[ __ ] did a show the other day a little
loaded
up man and they took it down
but the most impactful show i saw of his
and one of the things you know that i
constantly say on this show is that
we're real people have real
conversations of real time
about real stuff and what you just
touched on is what he talked about too
is about being your brother's keeper and
it don't make you weaker or soft if you
in a moment
you got to have that moment but we got
to be there for our brothers um to
prevent situations like little lotus so
i do appreciate i
really really sincerely appreciate you
adding that balance fam thank you
and that's the thing japan's a friend of
mine
and you know i would say i i've been
there for some
a friend of mine i had to sit up for
days with a brother
but but you also have somebody can do
that for you
and see with that comes a
re-establishment
of brotherly bonds of people that you're
not necessarily genetic
dna related to and trust
see what gets us as a community is
we don't trust each other
we don't we're not well that's like the
one when you open up to someone you
always run the risk that one
they're gonna tell other people like
what you said
right and then other people are gonna
look at you differently you also run the
risk
of you know them making fun of you or
like
not really giving you like empathy
um so i i could definitely see like why
people don't trust each other sure we
can trust each other
and and i get it that's why i have a
firm policy
i don't beef and i challenge you this
and and i don't talk i am like a vault
you tell me something it ain't never
gonna get out
now there's a machiavellian principle of
men
who want to be powerful collect favors
and secrets but there's also just a code
somebody who talks to me know that they
ain't gonna get out and you can play a
game telephone with me if you want you
can play a game of power if you want to
tell me something tell three other
people
it ain't never gonna get out of me and
somebody can tell you something and no
it's not going to get out
even in the worst circumstances
you both benefit because they still have
to have a begrudging amount of respect
for you
that's jordan peterson talks about
that's why the
marriage like the benefit of marriage
just to have someone
that you can just tell the truth to all
the time and you can't leave
but now it's so common to like leave
that it kind of changes things but like
the idea of marriage is there's someone
you can tell the truth to a hundred
percent of the time and they won't leave
if they can't stand you
kev i got a question for you before you
did real quick um
so i'm very careful when it comes to
aligning myself with certain people i i
i rock with people
i give them shout outs and stuff like
that but it seems as though
even though the manosphere is growing in
a positive way
overwhelmingly and it's a lot of people
doing a lot of great things
um you know i kind of pay attention to
how things sometimes go off the rails
depending on who's popping and who's not
at the time
you know what i'm saying so i guess my
question is how do you determine who you
lend what platforms you lend your voice
to
like how do you balance that how do you
figure out
or how long maybe do you
watch and evaluate whether or not you
want to rock with somebody and and
you know how do you determine whether or
not you really align it with somebody
versus being able to kind of have that
insight or that intuition of people
that's just doing stuff just for the
sake of
popularity or using your name or using
your platform or
using your voice and it's not
necessarily
in a positive way or it's not it's not
necessarily coming from a good space but
it's based off of
the fact that you are supporting a lot
of different people
and a lot of different platforms in a
lot of ways because you are a good
hearted person
well right now i i work with people on
different levels
but i'm really careful who are allowed
close to me because um
like you i work i work and i watch
see one thing o'shea will tell you he
always says that people don't recognize
how much work i do behind the scenes and
how much i'm watching
and i'm always watching so um
[Music]
i will lend my support to somebody who
agrees
on the basic fight on the basic message
but i'll also go back and look at
what they said in the past to make sure
that there can be a middle ground there
um
there's always going to be can it help
get the message out
to a greater audience uh and
and be in the form of some kind of a
hypocritical do no harm
this is why also um i'm kind of hesitant
to go places because
i'm not necessarily sure if the outcomes
that person wants
lines up with what i want but i
but i will say this in general i look at
the brand
and the brands align and if the brands
can align
that's okay but when i say that i'm not
just looking at my brand
and that brand i'm looking at my brand
and your brand
and jr's brandon and courtney's brand
and rila's brain and kay's brain
everybody i touch just like
will be touched by everybody i've
touched in the past
so i can't necessarily work with
somebody here
even if it's lucrative because that will
bring it into
the ecosystem of yeah that's that's
something you have to think about
being like a content creator the people
that you associate yourself with
then you become associated with them so
you kind of have to be careful
who you do collabs with and like do
different content creation stuff with
other people so if you can so i can't
be like you got dirt over here on the
you got some shady stuff over here where
i can't
have that necessarily reach over here
and is it perfect
no uh what i will say is
you're trying to work with the people uh
who are serious
uh that's one thing i try to work with
people who are serious and consistent
in trying to do this full-time um and
i've had to make that a
firm requirement in 2021
that if you're not a con if you don't
don't have a consistent broadcast time a
consistent platform consistent mess
consistent this
then i i'll just wait until you get to
that point
and then from that point you know i try
to do as much as i can
to help lend my what i can bring to a
platform
but i still look at myself as a content
creator
uh i don't i mean yeah i'm hot right now
that's cool
but it'll be somebody else's turn but
you got to always pay it
forward you know you don't ever want to
get too big to where
you can't still vibe with folks who are
not where you're at yet
if you're if you're a fan of uh you have
to be a fan of the man but rudyard
kipling
uh if you can walk with kings and not
lose the common touch
that's big for me because i understand
that my my persona
could come off as bougie elitist
arrogant standoffish who does a little
bit i'm not even gonna lie
this six foot full college time for it
and suit
this that uh who is this but then you
walk up to me and i'm like what's up man
how you doing they're like oh [ __ ] you
nicer than i thought i'm like
i ate fried chicken in
and we're the only group in america
that's like that to where
in our barber shop you can have
[Music]
the the um the the the dude that cuts
yards for a living no disrespect to
dudes to cut yards
and a guy whose vp emerges in
acquisition of goldman sachs and we all
get our hair cut at the same place
we're on the only we're the only culture
to where all of our
all our people kind of mix that way
that's unique that's actually really
true
because
like if i go get my hair cut
like it's a different it's a completely
different group if you go to like i've
been to a five dollar haircut place
before and i've been to like a bougie
haircut place honestly i didn't even
notice much of it different
but yeah i think he has a point and it
gives us an opportunity okay someone in
the comments said
your insert screen is larger than theirs
i can hardly see theirs i prefer you big
and
the size of the screen because i'm
trying to ask if you guys prefer me big
or small on the screen um do you guys
like the size of this right here
um like the screen so i can make it
bigger smaller i want to make it
so like the angle is good so let me know
in the comments the insight that other
people
don't because other folks they separate
um
but i also say this that for those of us
who are trying to do
great things you can't take this [ __ ]
personally
we put out too much content we're too
visible
we're too seen and if somebody wants to
they can find anything six months ago
you said
you're right five months ago you was
wearing a red hat
and you said you didn't say we you said
we
are you didn't say word you said all
right you got me
this can't take this [ __ ] personally
that's the thing about being a content
creator
is you have to pay so much more
attention to what you say and this is
probably one of my flaws as a content
creator
so i just kind of talk i'm not gonna lie
to you
um okay i'm watching a lot of your
videos i like the other screen bigger
um let me know in the comments keep
telling me if you like me big or the
like which way you like it
i do do music reactions the lot and the
lives
are they're like brand new i'm i just
got a new computer
and that's why i've been having all the
audio issues i've been trying to set up
my new computer
um but it like actually is a fast enough
computer to do lives on so these are
going to be
regular i just have to figure out what
schedule i want to do so this is kind of
just a test
hey care before you go to yeah this
could be the last
question but um before you came on we
spoke about
women marrying for the wrong reasons and
the question i posed was
are women destroying the image of
marriage
are women destroying the image of
marriage
men women man for the wrong reasons
uh i'm going to answer it this way i
think
that the merit
rom-coms in hollywood has destroyed the
image of marriage
um disney has destroyed the image of
marriage so it doesn't surprise me that
women are marrying for romantic love
um romantic love and
and that kind of stuff um so
sadly so many of our women are marrying
for true love and in my opinion
that's the wrong reason because that's
not what gets you through
do i have them per se no
i think you see courtney you can see she
looks kind of sad
i think she regrets not staying with her
baby daddy
that's the message that's pumped out big
but um but what i
am hopeful is now that we have people on
the airwaves
that folks can get the message when i
say f and i actually agree with that i
think
marriage is a lot more of a choice than
i think it's a lot more of a choice than
like love because
if you get married let's say you do what
everyone wants to do you get married for
50 years right that's the goal right you
want to be married to someone forever
not many people can actually do that if
you do that
you don't think there's gonna be a year
or two where you don't really like the
person
just like i don't know common sense
they're probably gonna be times when
you really aren't a fan of the person
you're with but
i don't know that's just life i i think
it's more of a choice that's just my
opinion
love i don't care about love starting to
hear more people
say hey man maybe we should go back to
an arranged system or this or that
because um that's what it really comes
down to um
i've been saying that i would be cool
with a um
arranged marriage for years
although i don't know if my parents
sometimes i like
i i can see the value in why people do
that you get to the point of marrying
for outcomes legacy
they were in a better position uh and i
think we have to
and that's why i'm also a big proponent
of blackmail media
run by black men for black men we have
to redefine
a lot of things from a male-centric
standpoint
okay we say women are getting married
for the wrong reasons let's take that
what are we going to do about it if the
wrong reasons benefit
the enemy or somebody else there's money
in it
that we got to do something different
now don't we
so we want women to marry for the right
reasons we got
to put the right reason out there in our
own voice
okay that's actually a really good point
um so oh my gosh
the one thing that is interesting about
kevin samuels
and i don't really understand about him
he
always preaches he always always always
preaches
that
like you should get married st mary did
like mother of your kids father of your
kids
you met your husband and blew it
whatever but
he he didn't stay married he's only been
married like three years
up and he's like 50. which i mean it's
fine i understand like
i understand i just he clearly could get
married if he wanted to
so it doesn't really make sense to me
that you're going to preach and tell
people to get married and stay married
and that's the way to do it if you're
not gonna
do it yourself you know um
just my two cents though okay this was
kind of like a test stream like i'm just
testing this right now
could you let me know in the comments
how i'm gonna i'm gonna see if i can
like
can i rearrange the screen live
oh okay cool i can okay let me know
how you think would be the best like way
to put the screen
i can make it a little bigger and go
like this
um
sorry if this is boring but i need to
know i need this feedback
because i could
it's more like he asks them if they want
to be married and they say yes yeah
that's true
i could put it more this way
so i could even go even like further
back and go like this
again this is just like a test right now
and then what would you guys want to see
in like shows if i did like a live
show weekly or something what would you
guys want to see
because i'm trying to get like a
consistent schedule but i need to know
what okay you guys that's too big for
you
okay more of me
and then i could put this a little
closer to me wait
okay um
but if i did a show what would you guys
want me to talk about
or see like would you want i'm just
trying to get like a live like the
reactions
um
so you guys still think the screen is
too big okay let's see
i don't know how to crop it out right
now so the top is gone but i'm gonna
figure out how to do that
um okay i would like
to to bring on blue-pilled women and
call them out on their hypocrisy it
would be fun watching you destroy oh my
gosh
oh i don't know if i'm the right person
for that
because i'm a lot i'm not like kevin i'm
not super dirt
like i'm not super like i'm usually
pretty
non-confrontational a little bit but i
could test it out and see if you know
it's any good
because
fresh and fit reactions are good maybe
alexander wait
grace
um okay so you'd wanted me to do like
live reactions
kevin is a weird situation he states he
lives by
mgtow what does that stand for
i think i should know that but i don't
um but he hates on
mgtows he's a walking hypocrisy
i mean i think he lives like some of the
stuff he preaches about i just i just
noticed when i found out he was only
married for like
for three years and he preaches that he
could get married and he wanted to if he
wanted to
and says that marriage is like the way
people should go
um but he's not married himself that's a
little bit where i see
a bit of the hypocrisy coming in
but i mean everyone is a hypocrite on
some level in my opinion
like if you talk to the average person
they genuinely
generally
preach one thing they don't do i would
guess
okay what else would you guys want in a
show i'm just trying to
talk to you guys on this live sorry if
this isn't super
you know uppity um
so we only listen to slim doctors that
don't smoke i
actually have a rule on this i don't go
to dentists with bad teeth and i won't
go to an overweight doctor
um if you c if you don't do the stuff
that you
that you say that you know about it
doesn't make sense for me like genuinely
i believe that so yeah
i wouldn't go to a doctor that smoked i
wouldn't go to a doctor that was
overweight
i wouldn't go to a dentist with bad
teeth i wouldn't
i wouldn't go to an overweight trainer
it's like the same thing
like genuinely that's all the same thing
okay
what you like about watch a show full of
fresh and fit and then
dissect the shows like a check on the
behavior and stuff like that okay
cool i'm just i'm trying to get like a
schedule put together and i'm just
trying to get
ideas for it maybe i'll make like a post
or something i'm gonna react to maybe
one more video
if you guys have one you want me to
react to
i'm so happy it's this took me like
three days to get this audio
i'm so bad at the equipment guys so bad
terrible actually
what do you go to a therapist that's not
crazy of course yeah and that's what i'm
saying
you would not
you would not want to go to someone
that doesn't practice the stuff
themselves that's why you know that's
why sometimes i'm a little bit hesitant
to give dating advice genuinely like i'm
genuinely hesitant because i'm not
married
and i genuinely believe to give dating
advice you should be married
um so
like like to be like genuinely taken
seriously
um because if you date you have the
intention of getting married so that's
why
i'm like somewhat hesitant to do that
you know um
i've seen a successful marriage but
like that i've never been in one
um okay do we link videos in the chat
um just give me the title and i'll
search it
well i'm married most married people are
miserable
i have not found that most married
people are miserable maybe most married
people that you know were miserable
but the married people i know tend to be
happier
than the single people i know genuinely
um
people that get married have kids and
stay married
in the long run i've seen be happier
than the people that i know that got
divorced or never got married
i think on some level we all respect
people that get married and stay married
you know um
do you know the difference between mgtow
red pill
red pill black pill purple pill all this
stuff is usually
norm normies so they label him i don't
know that most married people
are miserable at the end of their
marriage well
but see that's he said most married
people are miserable at the end of their
marriage so if a marriage ends of course
they're gonna be miserable near the end
duh um
okay
okay i'm gonna end this live uh